robert you mentioned previously that you
would not have embarked on kids for cash
if you could not tell the victim story
as well as the so-called villain story
so can you
recount us what it was like
the day you actually spoke to judge
shiverella and i mean where were you
what was it like
when you approached him to be in this
film well i think um to start we really
weren't going to make the movie unless
we could tell from the villain of
victim's point of view because i think
that's like the classic story you know
and and almost from the beginning it
seemed like a tale right out of the
charles dickens book you know and and
and so uh
the idea was to see if we could approach
him in fact my producing partner and i
thought there's no way we're going to
get these judges to talk why would they
they're they're about to under take a
federal prosecution why would they do it
but um i didn't know them but i knew of
them and i was able to get a meeting
with one of the judges judge cibrella
and it was my pitch was simple i said
listen this is a one-dimensional story
in the media you just maybe perhaps all
your life were scheming to
you know to for this to happen you know
to raise all this uh to put kids away
for for money and and i don't think it
happened that way but there must be
another side to this whole story and
and judges of course there's there's
always a side but nobody wants to hear
it like well i'm interested in hearing
it but but but if you agree to to work
with us we're going to tell the story
from both perspectives
and go wherever it goes and neither
judge knew that they were being filmed
neither judge
by agreement knew that they were being
filmed
but i can't be sure that they didn't
talk among themselves i i'm not sure
well they were friends in the very
beginning oh sure and they were enemies
at the end it's hard to know in between
if they had um talk to each other and i
don't know right so where was the first
meeting with judge ciprella where did it
take place
first meeting was in his daughter's home
uh because at this point judge cibrella
had you know sold his home so he's
living with his daughter so the first
meeting was there and uh you know
because he was kind of holed up there i
mean he didn't go out because when he
went out people would mob him
oh wow so it was that he was that well
known even by facebook oh yeah yeah i
mean we had to sneak our equipment into
the into the condo that he was living in
because
you know people would see like what are
they doing plus the fact that we didn't
want anyone to find out that he was
being interviewed um no one and and he
said in particular the other judge did
too that he didn't want his lawyer to
know either and so kind of a burden we
had to make sure that we brought our
crews in from new york and you know big
crew too a lot of equipment how do we
how are we going to get all this into
your place but we had to do it so that
you know neighbors and others didn't
know what we're doing and how did you do
that just putting stuff in bags yeah
just making you know like small like
going in with you know and look having
lookouts really like make sure that
people didn't know that we were around
and just take stuff in pieces at a time
show up in multiple vehicles park
different places you know so that we
didn't have a big crew of people walking
into the place and somehow we did it
it's just amazing to me too that that no
one knew that we were we were filming
them
and how many meetings did you have with
him
um we had
you know maybe um
seven or eight interviews over the
course of years with um with the judges
in different places
they went all in the same spot
when did you break the news to the
families of these kids that you had
obtained footage of the two judges
we
one of the things i dreaded in this film
was to to sharing the film with the
families um and all the projects that
we've done on fiction work that we've
done you know we say look you know we're
gonna show you the film before the
public sees it
privately in this particular case we
knew we i knew we would do that when it
was all done and i knew that would be
the first time they'd find out that the
villain the person they hated the most
perhaps in the whole world was in this
movie too and i dreaded it because i had
developed a rapport not just with the
judges and families but with both sides
i mean in other words i had a rapport
with both the villain and the victim
because the only way you can get an
interview you know they had to trust you
sure
so we um so we um
went into a regular movie theater one
family at a time and the first half hour
of the time that we blocked was me
telling them first i have to tell you
that judge shiverella and judge conahan
are in this movie
and let that sink in and of course they
were all shocked some felt betrayed
initially
and then we showed the movie and then we
spent the next hour after the movie
talking about their feelings about
what they just saw
and the the um the first screening for
all of them was a bit of a blur
but they were but but they saw it again
and over the course of time they've
really come to completely appreciate why
it's important to have the villain in
the film they all support the film i
mean even the judge's daughters the
judges haven't been able to see the film
but the judge of judge gibberella's
daughters have seen it as well
and
it's been remarkable i think it's one of
the most remarkable things about the
project for me is how the families have
reacted
to seeing themselves and having their
stories which are so personal
um you know
splayed open for the for the public to
see and how much integrity
they have displayed
it's pretty remarkable
so how does that feel to you that you
have basically the last footage of both
these men's lives i mean
what kind of responsibility do you feel
that places on you and and
did that affect you during the the
filming process i mean it's it's well i
i
the responsibility that i
felt through all of the project was
we're handling people's lives you know
even the villains lives these are the
lives and you know even though
shiverella took the money he shouldn't
have taken the money he admits to taking
the money admits that that part was
wrong he may never admit to kids for
cash but he also destroyed his family
his entire family and his friends and
all of it and they have to live with his
legacy
and you know it and and i think for us
we just wanted to have an honest
portrayal
of the stories and we we
said that we were not going to take
anything anybody says out of context we
had 600 hours of footage and you can
always
take and flip when you're editing you
know somebody something that's something
reality shows that's what it is it's a
constant flip of what people say so we
had to make sure that we we stayed true
to all the stories and and we did and
i'm very proud of that and and literally
from the journalists to the families to
the judge's daughters no one has come to
us and said we got it wrong we took
something out of context no that's not
right that's not what i meant no no one
has has said that and i feel really good
about that
knowing that you have two children what
15 and eighteen what's that right
thirteen and seventeen thirteen
seventeen okay i'm sorry fourteen and
seventeen
okay um
you must have thought about your own
family during the making of this and
being a parent can you talk about the
most emotional moment
during your years
collecting the interviews for kids for
cash
i'd say the most emotional moment was
listening to the kids tell their stories
and
you know feeling so helpless that the
first thing they all talked about was
the the moment they were handcuffed and
shackled
and
it was
for them to tell that story was just all
of us it got us all i mean our whole
team we would just be just be we have
the energy sucked out of us because
they wouldn't even talk about the
scandal first i mean the scandal was
secondary the first thing was handcuffed
and shackling and the and the fact that
they were being pulled away from their
families
it was incredible and then you know i'd
go home to my kids and i would
think about
geez it could be them it really could be
them and how would we feel
and and how would the kids feel and when
a kid is taken in the juvenile system
the parents lose all custody and control
of their kid there's nothing they can do
once that kid is adjudicated delinquent
so knowing that knowing that you went
back what would you have done i mean
there were some instances where there
were just the parents were going down
with the kids for a meeting and then
they ended up being taken away i believe
so could
you tell what maybe
you would have done if suppose one of
your children had gotten in trouble
whether it was a minor
scuffle at school something like that
and you were put in this position
well i would be a lot of the parents
that went there
um thought it was gonna work out okay
and they were surprised when their kid
was you know hauled away and handcuffed
some shackles
we screened the film in omaha
and
we
there was a parent that spoke up at the
end and they said their son went before
a juvenile court judge in omaha
and the kid couldn't speak he was so
frightened he couldn't speak so the
parents
were trying to help him and speak up for
him and the judge warned them twice to
keep their mouth shut and let the kid
talk but the third time the parents
spoke the judge literally had the
parents handcuffed shackled and arrested
and taken out of the courtroom in front
of the kid and then shortly thereafter
arrested the kid as well i would have
been that parent i would have been the
parent that would have literally
said to the you know judge you wait a
minute
but a lot of these parents were
threatened with being hauled out of the
courtroom if they didn't keep their
mouth shut
that's what would have happened to me
they would they would have had to
restrain me and take me out of the court
but that happened to parents
what were most the parents doing during
this time i realized that some of them
had said you know we weren't
lawyer on retainer type of people you
know we just sort of relied on the
goodness of others and and
family helped us but what were they
doing during these years that their kids
were denied release
over like minor things things that well
all of the parents tried to like once
their kid was in they kind of tried to
do something they would make phone calls
but perhaps they didn't make enough
calls i mean in hillary transu's case
her mother she was just going to keep
calling until someone said they could
help her but the difference between her
and the other parents was that she was a
social worker she was a very
well-educated social worker laureen tran
sue and she knew
that when she heard the words
adjudicated delinquent she knew what
that meant she knew that her kid was the
custody and control was just taken and
there wasn't anything she could do
so she had to do something to get her
out and she just was going to keep
calling until she found someone that's
when she found the juvenile law center
in philadelphia which turned out to be
their heroes from being in the community
from
being involved in this project for years
what has it taught you about people
being in this community in particular
that was so zero tolerant and i was too
like i believed in zero tolerance
even when i had my kids i mean i didn't
necessarily understand what it meant
um
and people say to me
how could no one have known you know
what was going on there you know people
even in the community say it or around
the country they say how could how could
people not know that this is all going
on
you know half the time there wasn't
lawyers in the courtroom and i always
say well there was always a lawyer in
the courtroom a prosecutor was there
there were all sorts of people in the
courtroom
the reason no one knew what was going on
we were all complacent and complicit
because we all believed in zero
tolerance we all thought you know be
tough on kids we were all fine with it
until
we found out there was millions of
dollars involved and all of a sudden we
weren't fine with the way the kids were
being treated anymore you know to me
that's hypocrisy i get to say it about
my own community because i lived in the
community
and i think that the community has to
catch up to that because when they blame
a single person for all that happened
they don't realize necessarily how
unrealistic that really is it takes a
village to raise a child it takes a
village to destroy a child as well
and i think that's a realization
that my community is coming to grips
with now and i think that more
communities around the country as they
see the film will come to grips with as
well and do you hope that others will
become more empathetic i think you
mentioned that you know you would see a
kid maybe and think well that's a bad
quote bad kid and as any parent would
they would want quote a bad kid to stay
away from their kids but i think you you
said that it made you soften a little
bit and and open your eyes to people's
situations a little more
it did and i think um i've um i have
i've always had some empathy but i used
to judge people much more harshly adults
and kids before this project i just did
i'd see somebody and i'd start to make a
judgment man i tell you it's my
whole automatic filters have changed
completely because of the project i
literally no longer look at people that
way and the thing about you know zero
tolerance is it it's black and white and
in this world there is no such thing as
zero tolerance as far as uh mechanical
things you know there's tolerance within
a certain level of tolerance and zero
tolerance means
it doesn't like why are we doing it to
kids or or or people
and i think that the zero tolerance idea
is i want zero tolerance for your kid
not mine because if my kid does
something wrong see i know my kid i know
where his intentions but it's your kid
that i worry about and when a kid is
labeled a juvenile delinquent no other
parent wants that kid to hang out with
their kid
because you know they're bad they're a
bad kid we've had people that have seen
the film in pre-release that have
contacted us one way or the other and
said they
they they'll never look at a kid the
same way again
which i think is great and and the fact
that you know they're not they'll be
less suspicious now because we've
created this suspicion about oh kids are
evil and they're going to do bad things
and i think that that'll i think that's
going to change i really do i believe
it's going to change if people enough
people see the film
what's your take on this new label of
affluenza
making a child
behave a certain way versus how
the court systems seem to view some of
these families
with their own bias thinking that oh
well maybe he came from a quote troubled
home
i think we all come from troubled homes
in a way i mean i you know show me a
family that doesn't have some level of
dysfunction
that's the problem we label
kids at risk i think all kids are at
risk and i think that schools who
contribute more kids into the juvenile
system since columbine than any other
time ever pennsylvania alone had a 300
increase in placing kids into the system
since columbine 300 yeah juvenile crime
has been coming down way before
columbine continues to come down
i i think that we have sort of lost our
way in the way that we look at kids and
i think we need to kind of pull
ourselves back and
and realize the kids are kids and let
kids live their lives and learn from the
mistakes they make just like we did when
we were growing up
and lastly on the facebook for kids for
cash you see just the outpour of
comments from people within the
community how's that been for you i mean
people are they just feel seems like
that the story is finally out in the
open it's finally being told but it
seems like there's more that they still
want to talk about i think the
interesting thing about facebook is that
you know when a movie like this first
comes to be you know you get a facebook
like or two but this had more facebook
likes than most any other in fact i
think than any other independent film of
late before the movie ever opened and
and the anticipation for it's been
overwhelming for us you know and i think
that's important though it's like when
people
like like our facebook page when they
like it it just shows support of what
the film's about and i think that the
kids feel that too because they're on
there they're watching those those
facebook likes and such they are and and
it and it's good
the kids feel finally they have a voice
and and i think they know they're
speaking for a lot of other kids and
families around the country which is a
really good feeling for them and for me
too